Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
Savez vous à quoi ressemblait notre planète
il y à plus de 2 milliards d'années ?
Non, c'était bien avant les dinosaures.
Jusqu'à maintenant on pensait qu'à cette
époque il n'y avait que des petites
bactéries qui flânaient tranquillement dans l'eau.
Sauf que des chercheurs de l'Université
de Poitiers ont récemment découvert
d'étonnantes traces fossiles.
Ces traces semblent indiquer qu'il existait déjà à l'époque
des bestioles composées de
plusieurs cellules
et que ces bestioles bougeaient.
Curieuses et curieux rien que
pour vous aujourd'hui la première
fibroscopie de l'histoire de la Terre.
Bien sûr, il ne s'agit pas des images
d'un examen médical
mais des traces de galeries
creusées par les ancêtres de nos ancêtres
de nos ancêtres de nos ancêtres
de nos ancêtres de nos ancêtres...
de nos ancêtres.
Et peut-être même les premières
traces de mobilité des êtres vivant
sur terre il y à 2,1 milliards d'années.
Avant de tout vous expliquer je pense
qu'il est temps de faire un petit point
histoire,  un point même vieille histoire
même très très vieille histoire...  très
très très vieille histoire
4 5 milliards d'années : formation de la planète terre.
On pense que les premières formes de vie très simples,
des bactéries faites d'une seule cellule sont apparues
il y à 3,5 milliards d'années.
Les dinos, eux, sont apparus il y à 250 millions d'années.
Et pour info, nous, homo-sapiens,
on débarque seulement il y a trois cent
mille ans
et Denver,  le dernier dinosaure, c'était fin des années 80.
Entre bactéries primitives et dinosaures
la vie a donc évolué.
Et pas qu'un peu, mon
neveu !
Jusqu'ici on estimait que les premiers organismes complexes et mobiles
étaient apparus il y à 560 millions d'années.
Mais la découverte qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui
repousse cette apparition de...
1,5 milliard d'années !
Soit il y à environ 2,1 milliards d'années.
Bon, cette date est estimée à plus ou
moins 300 millions d'années,
mais on n'est plus à ça près.
C'est au Gabon, dans les roches de cette carrière,
que les chercheurs ont trouvé ces étonnantes traces de galeries.
Ils ont obtenu la morphologie en trois dimensions de la roche par microtomographie.
La microtomographie fonctionne comme un scanner médical :
chaque fossile peut ainsi être finement
analysé et sa structure reconstituée.
Vous vous souvenez,  je vous avais déjà
expliqué cette technique
dans l'épisode sur l'oreille de l'ancêtre des baleines.
Revenons à nos galeries : les chercheurs
ont voulu s'assurer tout d'abord
qu'il s'agissait bien de traces laissées par
des organismes vivants.
Ils ont donc comparé ces galeries à de nombreuses structures
naturellement observées dans les roches
mais ils n'ont rien trouvé de similaire.
Ces traces ont donc de fortes chances d'être ce que l'on appelle
des traces biotiques, donc liées au vivant.
Et les traces biotiques, c'est pas
automatique.
Bon, là, comme moi, vous vous demandez
comment peut-on être sûr que ces
galeries ont été creusées par de petites
créatures il y a plus de 2 milliards d'années.
Et bien plusieurs indices viennent soutenir l'hypothèse des chercheurs :
Les trajectoires que l'on observe sont sinueuses
et traversent les différentes couches de sédiments,
parfois à l'oblique, et même à la verticale.
Ces premières observations sont
caractéristiques d'un mouvement actif
dans un sédiment encore assez mou pour
avoir été creusé.
A l'époque, la roche n'avait pas encore totalement sédimenté,
et c'était probablement une sorte de vase.
Donc les tunnels aurait le même âge
que la roche.
Vous suivez ?  Et il se trouve que cette
roche a été datée
à 2,1 milliards d'années par plusieurs équipes de scientifiques.
Et c'est pas fini !
Des analyses chimiques ont montré la
présence de soufre dit " biologique "
dans les galeries.
Actuellement ce type de
soufre n'est retrouvé que dans les sédiments
qui se sont formés en présence
de matière organique.
C'est le cas lorsqu'un organisme se
décompose sur place, ou par exemple
lorsqu'une limace laisse une traînée de
mucus derrière elle.
Les chercheurs pensent que les organismes
à l'origine de ces tunnels seraient une agrégation de cellules simples
unies pour explorer la
vase à la recherche de nutriments.
A la recherche du brownie perdu !
La forme des galeries nous permet d'imaginer
à quoi ressemblaient ces mystérieux
organismes mobiles :
A une sorte de ver de quelques millimètres d'épaisseur.
C'est un petit pas pour un agglomérat de cellules,
mais un rampement de géant pour l'humanité.
Allez, je vous laisse refaire un tour !
En tout cas, on retiendra que les
premiers mouvements sur Terre
sont probablement nés dans le but d'aller
casser la croûte...
terrestre.
Sur ce, j'y vais, j'ai un brownie qui m'attend.
Et pour ne pas manquer les prochains épisodes
abonne-toi !